Your mission, should you
choose to accept it is to
build a Google Gadget.
The challenge: making it
original, useful,
and customizable.
I'm Dan Le, with
the Google Gadgets team.
I'm here to brief you
on your mission.
Googe Gadgets can give you
the time, weather,
sport scores, or pull feeds
from YouTube.
They gather information from
around the internet and
display it for you
in a convenient way.
You can find many other
gadgets in the
iGoogle directory.
Now let's look at how
you build a gadget.
We'll start with a simple
version and get more
complex as we go.
This gadget fetches and
displays multiple RSS and Atom
feeds from all over the web.
It uses multiple
API features and
is highly configurable.
Let's select the
basic parameters.
Say you really like R&B music.
You might then customize this
gadget to pull together the
latest R&B music editions
on YouTube, Amazon, and
iTunes, as well as pull the
latest entries from
your favorite music blog.
You can create a
separate tab for each feed.
You should start small by
creating a simple gadget XML
that just has the basics.
You can make the gadget
more complex as you go.
The code here determines the
title and height
of the gadget.
Now you need to
add tabs to the gadget.
Add
'<Require feature="tabs"/>'
to the gadget XML, which
enables the use of
the API tabs library.
You will generate unique
content for each tab in
the callback function.
Now you have the basic
gadget shell with four tabs.
The next step is to pull an
RSS or Atom feed for each tab.
You will define the default
value for each URL feed that
will be loaded, but you will
add UserPrefs so that users
can configure their own data
when they use your gadget.
From the data you can display
different types of information
about the feeds, such as its
name, display name,
description, feed entry,
and summaries.
Once you have completed this
step, users will be able to
change the input feed URLs.
Next, within your gadget, you
should perform the fetch.
We have an API method
called "_IG_FetchFeedAsJSON."
This is used to perform a
fetch to the feed and return a
"JSON" response back to the
callback function
that you define.
Within the callback, use a
"JSON" object to
read the feed.
The second parameter is where
you specify the
callback function.
The third parameter defines
the number of entries
you want to fetch.
The fourth parameter is a
simple true or false depending
on whether you want to include
summaries for each entry.
This large code snippet shows
the callback function that
generates the HTML based on
the "JSON" data
that is returned.
Let's see what the
gadget looks like now.
Now the gadget is able to
execute the basic functions
you've set for it to perform.
How can you improve its
appearance and performance.
First, you'll be responsible
for formatting the
UI of the gadget.
You can add CSS rules to
stylize the output
for the gadget.
But keep in mind some key
points about UI design.
Gadgets should be
as compact as possible.
Real estate on
iGoogle is limited.
You can keep gadgets compact
by using single boarder lines,
decreasing margins, and
applying formatting to the
tabs, such as
smaller font size.
Take another look at the
gadget to see what difference
these CSS rules have made.
Since the amount of
information from your feeds
will change often, you can
combat the changing need for
space this creates with
the "Dynamic-Height feature."
This feature will
automatically resize your
gadget so that it will best
fit the amount of information
coming from your feeds.
It will prevent your gadget
from taking up
unnecessary space.
You can also add the analytics
feature, a single function
call to "_IG_Analytics."
All you need is a Google
Analytics account, which is
completely free.
Passing your Google Analytics
ID as a first parameter.
For the second parameter, you
identify a unique path
specific to your gadget.
This function will report a
page you hit back to your
account, and lets you know how
many hits are coming
from your gadget.
Now you can put the final
touches on the gadget.
The more customizable it is,
the better.
When deciding what to add,
just keep in mind the features
you would like to have if you
were using this gadget.
For instance, you might want
the ability to change the
titles, tab labels, and number
of feed entries to display.
Here are a few code snippets
that show what's required to
make the gadget title
and tab titles customizable.
The last customizable feature
you can add is to allow the
user to specify how many feed
entries the gadget
should accept.
Before, the code has specified
specified there will be
three feed entries.
You can also define a drop
down menu for the feeds.
We replaced the hard-coded
part of the number of entries
with this user pref.
So now you've built
your gadget.
The last step is to
put your gadget into action.
How do you get it in
the gadget directory?
Submit your gadget to iGoogle.
In order to be able to submit
this gadget, you need to
add some metadata
about your gadget.
This information is what will
be used to help make your
gadget more searchable
in iGoogle's directory.
Remember, users will have
thousands of gadgets to choose
from in the gadget directory.
So you must attract the user
to your gadget when
they are browsing.
Some key ways to do so are to:
Find a catchy title
for your gadget.
Make it short and descriptive.
A user should be able to know
exactly what your gadget
does by the title.
Design an attractive thumbnail
and screenshot.
Images are important, as this
may be the only thing that
attracts the user to
your gadget.
Make the thumbnail stand out
and encourage the user
to click on it.
Once its listed on the iGoogle
directory, get to work on
promoting your gadget.
On your own website, you can
add the "Add to Google" button.
There's also a share gadget
feature on iGoogle, which lets
you send it to your friends.
If you have questions about
the gadget's API, there's a
public discussion group that
we encourage you to
become involved in.
Members on my team moderate
this group and answer
questions as they come up.
There are more than 3500
members in this group, and
its a great resource.
You have now been briefed
on your mission.
Good luck.
Submit your gadget soon.
The clock is ticking.